here with more on the upcoming midterms
last night's big winner out of wyoming
harriet hegman is with us harry
congratulations uh looks like all the
polls were
accurate
what do you think happened what why like
for example i thought back and i i
didn't remember liz cheney uh speaking
out when hillary clinton's dirty dossier
was being used by the fbi and abusing
power
uh and and lying before fisa courts why
is it what is it about donald trump that
that seems to trigger her more than
anything else
well i'm not quite sure sean and thank
you for having me on this evening
yesterday was a great day for wyoming
and really a great day for the country i
don't know that i can get into liz
cheney's mind nor do i really want to i
guess what i would say is that the the
folks of wyoming have spoken and they
have made it clear that they believe
they're entitled to a representative in
congress that represents their interest
and doesn't uh intend to pursue a
one-woman
war against donald trump we didn't send
her to washington d.c to be the judge
and jury of donald trump we sent her to
washington dc to block the radical biden
agenda to block the radical pelosi
agenda and she signed on with both of
them so yesterday wyoming spoke and said
we've had enough we're fed up we're
going to take our country back we're
starting right here in wyoming let's
talk about i watched her speech last
night
i think she's sincere in her beliefs
she's allowed to believe anything that
she wants pursue any agenda that she
wants but clearly at some point she got
out of touch with the people of wyoming
which is why you won by such an
overwhelming margin she mentioned that
she called you i didn't hear in that
sentence that she congratulated you and
wished you well how did the call go
well there wasn't a phone call while i
was going in and getting ready to do my
acceptance speech last night and had
just arrived at the watch party she
called and left a very brief two-second
message on my on my cell phone that's
the extent of it i haven't had any other
contact with liz cheney she only made
the one effort and all she said was
hello harriet and then that was the end
of it so
she didn't call and discuss with me any
kind of concession or anything else it
was just a one phone call i was
obviously extremely busy with family and
friends
she she just said hello harriet and hung
up
that was the end of the call yes that
was that was the only time it was about
8 15 last night and i was just getting
ready to go on stage with my accepted
speech and i didn't have an opportunity
to visit with her
okay well we're looking for
obviously i think you are a lot to win
this seat uh the people of wyoming sent
a very loud message last night we wish
you a lot of luck and when you go to
that sewer that swamp in washington
please don't let that sewer change who
you are because it changes a lot we're
going to change washington d.c
all right harriet hegman thank you
congratulations hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else